so what's going to happen with the  second impeachment trial of former  president donald trump well at this  point it's sort of anyone's guess  because remember  the senate basically negotiates the  rules every time they do it and in this  case something really weird is going on  because chief justice of the supreme  court john roberts is not going to  preside over the trial instead it's  going to be democratic senator patrick  leahy and that seems weird because the  constitution seems to contemplate the  chief justice of the supreme court now  experts disagree but in the case of a  former president it's not entirely clear  that the supreme court justice  must actually preside and since the  senate is basically making up the rules  as they go along it's probably going to  be okay and frankly it would be a  political question if anyone tried to  challenge it in court anyway so we'll  see what happens with this new  impeachment and i'll see you  in court